bonsoir à tous mario
en fait je vais surtout vous parler
d'énergie et à la fin de l'exposé un
tout petit peu de ce qu'on essaye de
faire
la première chose que je voulais vous
dire c'est que la actuellement je
consomme une puissance de 100 watts vous
aussi d'ailleurs
au repos l'être humain consomme 100
watts et ça ça fait environ
on est là 100 watts 10 puissance de
watts
ça ne fait pas environ ça fait
exactement 2400 water en une journée
et là on parle d'énergie 100 watts par
24 heures de 1400 watts heure de kilos
2,4 kilowattheures et de l'autre côté ce
qu'on consomme en france ce qu'on
utilise plus exactement c'est 1800
térawattheures par an et donc pour
illustrer un peu cette énorme quantité
d'énergie qu'on utilise
eh bien on peut se représenter par
exemple un homme qui pédalent ray sur un
vélo et qui produirait d'énergie pour
nous autres et ce bonhomme qui
ray disons 35 heures par semaine
quelques congés il ferait si j'ai bien
fait mes calculs 150 kilowatts heure par
an
voilà donc on et 66 millions
ça fait 181 bonhomme par personne pour
faire l'énergie qu'on utilise
voilà donc ça c'est la théorie des
esclaves énergétique n'est pas de moi
jean marc que jean-marc jean marc
jancovici en parle mais lui par contre
il est pas trop pour les éoliennes alors
je vais essayer de vous expliquer
pourquoi moi je pense que c'est une
bonne idée
donc ça c'est à quoi servent ses 1800
térawattheures un tiers à peu près pour
nous déplacer
on sait comment économiser moi je suis
pas particulièrement un exemple donc je
veux pas vous donner de conseils mais on
sait que le vélo le covoiturage etc
le train sont des vecteurs pour réduire
cette consommation énergétique
et puis l'autre tierces et les logements
en particulier le chauffage qui sert à
chauffer nos habitations et là je vous
invite à aller voir les agences locales
de l'énergie qui pourront vous aider
gratuitement vous conseiller pour
réduire votre facture énergétique faire
les bons investissements au bon endroit
voilà donc je suis les petites adresses
mail sur brest brest et énergie ce point
net et en bretagne sud c'est halloween
point fr
d'où viennent ses 1800 térawattheures eh
bien ils viennent en majorité de la
grosse zone qui est rouge là c'est le
pétrole et puis le gaz aussi enfin bref
beaucoup d'énergie fossile et puis pour
ce qui est de la france on à
l'électricité qui est produite à 75 %
par du nucléaire c'est à dire une part
electric 1 de 450 à 500 térawattheures
par an voilà donc si on sème à slide
suivante le pétrole c'est quand même
quelque chose qui est fantastique et je
vais les illustrée par le cas d'une
voiture qui roulerait pendant une heure
sur du plat à 100 km/heure donc 100 km
elle va avoir besoin de 10 kilowatts
heure et 10 kilowatts heure c'est on va
vous le savez pas ce que vous avez des
voitures et une voiture économique
conduit doucement ça fait 4 litres aux
cent
et ce à quatre litres aux cent j'ai pris
en compte le rendement du moteur et je
prend aussi en compte le rendement de la
centrale nucléaire
et j'en parlerai un petit peu enfin
avant de parler de centrales nucléaires
je parlais de batterie c'est à dire que
pour 4 litres d'essence quantité
d'essence c'est exactement équivalent à
55 kg de batteries lithium-ion sans le
poids de leur enveloppe
c'est à dire que le lithium ion ça brûle
assez facilement en cas de choc
donc on met quand même des carapaces
assez costaud pour paquet de problèmes
dans les voitures électriques qui sont
équipés de lithium ion comme la renault
zoé ou ou la tesla
donc voilà 55 kg de lithium ion et ça
c'est une énervant on peut charger ses
55 kg avec 38 mg d'uranium enrichi c'est
là qu'on voit que c'est le titre le
nucléaire faut reconnaître que c'est
magique 38 mg d'uranium enrichi donc 3 %
de 20 grammes c'est beaucoup ça fait ça
fait ça alors après si on passe à
l'éolien passer un petit peu plus
compliqué pour charger cette batterie de
55 kg
il nous faut 180 m² d'une éolienne qui
tournerait une éolienne en mer ce que ça
marche un peu mieux sur terre qui
tournerait pendant une heure voilà donc
on peut se poser la question de 2
pourquoi nos voisins font du
renouvelable parce que ça ça c'est la
part d'électricité qui est produite à
base de renouvelables au royaume uni en
bleu en bas en france en verre au milieu
et en allemagne en haut vous voyez que
les allemands sont passés de moins de
10% au début des années 2000 à plus de
30% aujourd'hui et il vise 90 % de leur
production électrique à base de
renouvelables en france c'est surtout
les barrages et les barrages
hydroélectriques qui font cette quantité
d'énergie la fin de cette production
électrique et le royaume uni eux ils
sont passés de aller 3 3 % à + 17 % et
aujourd'hui 5 % d'électricité au royaume
uni est produite avec des éoliennes
offshore alors se poser la question
pourquoi font-ils du renouvelable
j'imagine que vous avez tous une
excellente réponse à cette question on
entendra parler de réchauffement
climatique c'est certain moi je préfère
parler de pollution pollution risque
nucléaire suffit du charbon en chine
pollution c'est le premier premier point
le deuxième point c'est que les
ressources s'épuisent
donc on n'est pas bien sûr de combien on
notre pétrole parce que on retrouve
toujours des nouvelles réserves mais en
gros on est entre 45 45 années au rythme
actuel et 150 ans de pétrole pour les
plus optimistes
et puis on a un peu plus d'un siècle
pour le charbon un peu moins d'un siècle
pour le gaz pareil pour l'uranium
la troisième raison pour laquelle
personnellement je m'investis dans
l'éolien offshore flottant sait aussi
que c'est une source d'indépendance
énergétique et de on va dire
indépendance énergétique ça veut dire
moins de conflits énergétiques ça veut
dire moins de coût humain on a dépensé
en france 1 milliard d'euros l'année
dernière où cette année je sais plus
pour les opérations militaires
extérieures
voilà coût humain pour les autres pour
les populations impactées par les
guerres énergétique ou pour les
opérations militaires
bon ça c'est un point de vue très
personnel ce qui est sûr c'est que pour
en faire il faut que ça soit rentable et
donc les investisseurs y mettre des sous
dans les produits qui sont rentables
alors comment on calcule le marqueur de
la rentabilité eh bien on définir un
calcul on définir ce qu'on appelle un
coût de production
ce coût de production il est calculé en
divisant en gros tout ce qu'on dépense
par tout ce qu'on produit dont ce qu'on
dépense et acheter les machines c'est
les entretenir
donc les entretenir ça veut dire pour
les éoliennes offshore aller en mer
c'est vrai que c'est une partie non
négligeable du coup du coup des aînés
des éoliennes offshore
et puis le combustible le groupe va nous
le vent c'est gratuit donc c'est pas mal
mais bon il faut compenser le reste et
on divise tout ça par l'énergie produite
donc je rappelle que ce coup il prend
pas en compte ces fameuses externalités
qui sont le coût du démantèlement
nucléaire
le coût des risques nucléaires le coût
des guerres etc
mais bon c'est la loi du marché c'est
comme ça a alors la slate suivante donc
c'est pour illustrer ce coût de
production donc vous avez à gauche
le coût du nucléaire en france 65 euros
par mégawattheure
la cour des comptes en prenant en compte
le grand carénage de 50 milliards
d'euros ou peut-être je me trompe mais
enfin une somme faramineuse pour mettre
à jour les pour prolonger la durée de
vie jusqu'à 110 euros ça va être
vraisemblablement le prix auquel
l'électricité de le père anglais s'il
est fabriqué sera vendu parce que c'est
un petit peu plus cher c'est plus neuf
etc
le gaz ces volatiles c'est aux alentours
de 80 euros
l'éolien terrestre très bien les halls
intéresse surtout en bretagne
parce que dès qu'il ya du vent le
rendement s'améliore enfin la
rentabilité économique
quant aux éoliennes offshore est bien là
le coup le coup il dépend pas mal des
pays en fait nous on n'est pas très bien
placé parce qu'on est nouveau dans la
course et les futurs champs dont celui
qui devrait voir le jour à saint brieuc
sont aux alentours de 225 euros par
mégawatt/heure alors c'est sans doute
lié aussi au fait que c'est une nouvelle
industrie pour pour nous mais en tout
cas les les britanniques eux voient
leurs coûts descendre régulièrement
aujourd'hui on est en dessous de 150
euros par mégawattheure et puis les
danois qui sont les pionniers dans ce
secteur il fabrique des parcs
aujourd'hui à 103 euros par
mégawattheure voilà ce que c'est
l'éolien offshore industrielle
aujourd'hui c'est quelque chose que fixe
il faut bien se le représenter c'est à
dire que l'éolienne va être posée sur
une mono pile dans 80% des cas ce qu'on
appelle une mono pile c'est une tige qui
va descendre jusqu'au fond de l'eau et
même s'enfoncer à 30 mètres sous le sol
pour bien tenir il ya d'autres
technologies mais c'est la plus répandue
voilà et elles sont majoritairement
localisés dans la partie rouge que vous
voyez là donc la mer du nord
un petit peu la mer baltique et cette
zone a la particularité donc d'être
colorier majoritairement en jaune et en
verre sur cette carte qui veut dire
jaune moins de 30 mètres de fond vert
moins de 50 mètres de fond
donc vous voyez où je veux en venir on a
pas partout des sols de profondeur
modérés comme en mer du nord
voilà donc le premier avantage de
l'éolien flottant c'est qu'on peut en
mettre dans des vastes
des vastes zones pardon la deuxième
raison c'est que que le sol soit très
durs comme vraisemblablement à saint
brieuc ou du coup on peut pas vraiment
mettre de mots nos piles et on est
obligé de mettre des structures plus
cher que le sol soit très doux très dur
tu que le sol soit très mou on peut
mettre des éoliennes flottantes
c'est invisible des côtes on peut les
mettre plus loin des côtes donc ça
dérange moins les gens qui ont la chance
d'avoir une vue mer et qui ne veulent
pas voir des éoliennes au large les
immenses espaces disponibles c'est un
petit peu une répétition ont été mal
préparé ce talk et puis le dernier point
c'est que ces éoliennes on peut les
fabriquer au port et ça c'est un
bénéfice sur le coup parce que tout ce
qu'on fait en mer ça coûte beaucoup de
ça coûte beaucoup d'argent donc si on
peut fabriquer les éoliennes au port
comme l'exemple qui est montré sur votre
gauche ça c'est une éolienne offshore
flottante prototype l'une des quatre qui
a été fabriqué dans le monde à ce jour
quatre ou cinq à quelques voix là et
donc vous voyez elle a été fabriquée
dans ce qu'on appelle une forme un rat
double et l'éolienne est installé sur la
structure flottante et ensuite on tire
le tout pour allaient l'emmener au large
par opposition les parcs éoliens
industriels aujourd'hui
eh bien ils sont construits de la
manière suivante d'abord on va planter
ses fameuses monop' il avec des
techniques qui s'améliore de jour en
jour pour pas faire de bruit parce qu'on
les plantes avec des sortes de gros
marteau hydraulique donc c'est les
petites et petites têtes jaune que vous
voyez ici la voilà et puis ensuite on
est obligé de faire revenir ce qu'on
appelle un navire une barge élévatrices
qui coûte très très cher en location
pour d'abord posé la tour puis ensuite
posé la nacelle puis les pales donc ça
ça coûte des sous notamment parce qu'on
peut pas le faire tout le temps ils vont
pouvoir le faire facilement en hiver
enfin on peut le faire quand les vaccins
sont sont relativement modérés
voilà alors le je vous parlais
d'immenses espaces disponibles si on
fait le calcul pour la france donc ça
c'est ce que je veux ce dont je vous
parle la ccl un potentiel technique
c'est avec les espaces disponibles en
considérant une densité de 8 mégawatts
par kilomètre carré
c'est la puissance installée en
considérant que les éoliennes ne
fonctionne pas tout le temps à pleine
puissance ça dépend du vent on trouve
que l'on peut démontrer que en prenant
une scie zone de 50 km sur 50 km donc
c'est quand même des zones qui sont
conséquentes ins et j'ai marqué exemple
2050 c'est un exemple et puis c'est pas
pour demain c'est pour 2050 par exemple
un peu avant si on a vraiment envie de
le faire mais toujours est il que ça ça
va produire 420 térawattheures par an et
en gros 4 120 térawattheures par an
c'est la production électronucléaire
française et c'est aussi peu ou prou le
besoin d'électricité qu'on a dont on a
besoin en france donc ça c'est
équivalent à 60 centrales de 1000
mégawatts qui fonctionne qui
fonctionnerait à 80% du temps c'est à
dire qu'il ya aussi de la maintenance
sur les centrales nucléaires
un petit peu moins sur les centrales à
gaz mais elle ne fonctionne pas tout le
temps et donc ces éoliennes permettrait
de remplacer entre guillemets 1400
tonnes d'uranium enrichi par an ou bien
60 milliards de mètres cubes de gaz par
an 60 milliards de mètres cubes moi j'ai
refait plusieurs fois le calcul est ou
plutôt 100 millions de tonnes de pétrole
par an voilà alors ça c'est pour montrer
que les éoliennes flottantes
c'est bien avancé en tout cas c'est pas
une lubie d'ingénieur il y en a au moins
quatre qui flotte dans le monde et qui
fonctionne la première à gauche qui
consiste en un long cylindre flottant
qui a été réalisé en écosse en 2009
et puis ces petites soeurs ou plutôt ses
grandes soeurs vont voir le jour
j'ai dit une bêtise en norvège a été
installée en 2009 ses grandes soeurs
vont être installés en écosse l'année
prochaine en cinq exemplaires c'est
celle qui sont à gauche
elles sont un petit peu moins profond de
mes plus grandes et puis au milieu on en
a déjà parlé et à droite c'est les
japonais qui après fukushima on investit
beaucoup d'argent pour déployer ses
éoliennes flottantes de manière
prototype pour l'instant bientôt en
france parce qu'il y en avait un projet
de l'ademe pour réaliser des fermes
pilotes dont on aura les résultats
vraisemblablement au cours de cette
année
alors j'en viens un petit peu à ce sur
quoi je travaille au sein de la société
et all inks voilà donc ce que je vous
pour essayer de vous faire comprendre
notre idée je voudrais vous pointez du
doigt le fait que les éoliennes fixe
onshore c'est-à-dire terrestre ou en mer
mais fixe sont toujours posés sur un mât
et ça ça s'explique par le fait que la
nacelle elle doit pouvoir tourner donc
la nacelle c'est la partie qui en haut
elle doit pouvoir tourner pour
s'orienter face au vent en mer c'est un
petit peu différent enfin disons que on
a un degré de liberté supplémentaire
parce qu'on peut on peut faire tourner
l'ensemble de la structure la structure
donc ce que j'ai oublié de dire c'est
que ce mât il quand on augmente la
taille des éoliennes il est plus haut et
il est davantage soumis à des vibrations
et il pose pas mal de problèmes au
niveau des contraintes en pied de mât
donc ces deux c2 ces deux problèmes ont
été notamment à la source de notre
réflexion pour proposer une solution
innovante et donc comme je vous le
disais en mer on a un paradigme un petit
peu différent c'est à dire qu'on est
plus obligé d'avoir ce mât et on peut
imaginer une structure pyramidale et ce
serait l'ensemble c'est l'ensemble de
cette structure qui va s'orienter face
au vent en tournant autour de cet axe
virtuel que je représentais en rouge
pointillé
voilà donc ça c'est le concept 5
mégawatts qui est l'image que nous
diffusons partout on travaille
actuellement sur un concept de 10
mégawatts dont on garde un petit peu le
secret pour nous qui est assez proche de
ça mais il ya quelques différences qu'on
veut pas trop partager avec nos confions
euros pour l'instant et donc il faut
voir que le rotor tourne au milieu de
cette pyramide
voilà donc c'était en gros l'essentiel
du message que je voulais partager avec
vous je pourrais passer des heures à
vous parler de des spécificités de notre
concept voilà on pense vraiment que
l'éolien est une source d'énergie
considérable à l'instar de nos camarades
qui travaillent sur le déplacement à la
voile le vent est une source d'énergie
très importante et on espère
bien faire avancer le schmilblick en
proposant des solutions qui réduisent
les coûts et qui permettent de rendre
cette filière très compétitive
voilà je vous remercie